النظام بعد عن الحكم بعيد عن الحكم كغيرها
من
الحركات التي
اراد الشعب ان يبعدها اذا كان هناك قرار
لابعاد حركه من الحركات فلا غير في ذلك
انتم تعلمون بان الاحزاب في العالم الغربي
تتداولوا على الحكم يسقط الجمهوريون ويصعد
الديمقراطيون يبقون ثمانيه سنوات ينزلون
يسقط الثاني العمال والمحافظون هذا طبيعي
جدا
ولا يتصور ان الحركات الاسلاميه تريد ان
تبقى في الحكم ابدا الدهر لان الدوام ليس
من شيمه الحركات السياسيه حركه سياسيه
تعالج واقعا متغيرا ينبغي ان تنسحب عن
الحكم اذا لم تكن قادره على ان تقدم
لمجتمعها ما يصليحه لا يعني ذلك انها لا
تصلح ابدا وانا ما يعني ذلك ان عليها ان
تتطور ان تاخذ باسباب المعرفه ان تفهم
الواقع من جديد وان تحين خياراتها وان
تقوم بالرقابه الذاتيه على نفسها
لتبين اخطائها تتبينها واذا اخطات فلا
تتاخروا عن ان تقول انا اخطات لان
الاعتراف بالخطا فضيله بل اعتراف بالخطا
سبب
قوه يجب ان يحاسب اذا كان يتحكم في مصير
شعب اليس كذلك سيد عبد الفتاح
يقيلا يقينا الخطا وخطاان
خطا سهوا
وخطا
وخطا العمد يجب ان يحاسب صاحبه
صاحبه سياسيه
[موسيقى]
المرفوعه عليه قضايا الذي يحمله الكثير
يعني مسؤوليات ما يحدث في في تونس عن رموز
حركه النهضه في فتره في فتره حكم انت معهد
توجهنا
سيدي انا
عضو في هيئه الدفاع كمحامل
ومكتبي منخرط في بعض هذه القضايا للدفاع
عن افراد منهم الاستاذ راشد
والاحترام لمهنتنا كمحامين يفرض علينا الا
نعلق على المحاكمات حتى تنتهي
وذلك لا استطيع ان اخذ في واقعي احداث
يتصدى لها القضاه الشرفاء الكرام الذين
نحترمهم ونحن ننتظر مالات ذلك ومعركتنا هي
معركه داخل قصور العداله داخل المحاكم
وليست خارجه